MALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE]
Wave APIs, and I'm going to give
a quick one on behalf of
Wave [INAUDIBLE].
PAMELA FOX: All right.
Sorry to break up riveting
discussions.
You guys will have a lot
to do to keep it going.
So I worked on the Wave API for
the last year, and did a
lot of fielding developers'
feature requests, and did a
lot of discussion of what the
API should look like.
When we launched Google Wave
to developers last year, we
had a basic Robots API, number
one, and we had a basic Gadget
API, and that was
basically it.
And then in the course of the
year, we revised the Robots
API to do V2, which is what
you guys are probably
familiar with now.
MALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE]
PAMELA FOX: What?
MALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE].
PAMELA FOX: Oh, yeah,
yeah, sorry.
And then we also introduced an
Embed API, and also Wave This,
and also a Wave Data API,
which was like an
authenticated user version
of the Wave Robot API.
So we actually made a lot of
progress on the APIs during
the year, but there are
definitely still drafts, and
there's still a lot of things
that they could be, a lot of
features they could have, and
also sometimes completely
different ways of doing
those APIs.
So since you guys are going
to be doing your own wave
servers, and presumably you're
probably going to be
supporting the APIs, I just
wanted to talk briefly about
some of the ideas that we had
about what features we would
add or what APIs we would add.
So one type of API was
the Extensions.
How many of you guys actually
used the APIs
during the last year?
OK, a fair few.
And presumably, most of you have
actually used a gadget
and used a robot
in your waves.
So for extensions, we have
robots, and we have gadgets.
So for robots, the whole idea
was programmatic manipulation
of the waves.
And just to remind you what
robot code looks like, this is
a really basic Python robot.
We have a profile, we register
for events, we respond to the
events by doing some actions
on the blip, or on the
wavelet, or on the
participants.
So that's our basic Robot API.
So the ways we wanted to extend
it is first just in
terms of features.
The whole point of robots is
that they should be able to do
what human users can do.
And we got robots close to that,
but there was still a
lot that they're missing.
And if robots can't do
everything humans can do,
they're really pretty
handicapped.
So one of the big things was
being able to be able to
manipulate the conversation
model, being able to actually
move threads, move
blips around.
We had really basic conversation
model support,
but nothing like what
people wanted.
Because they wanted robots
that could actually
restructure these
conversations.
Another thing was for robots to
be able to search their own
waves that they were on.
A user can search their waves.
Robots should to be
able to as well.
Another thing is having robots
actually able to
be a part of a group.
One of the big issues is that
with the way our permissions
model worked, a robot couldn't
actually add a group to a wave
if that group had restricted
permissions.
Because a group is saying,
like, all right, the only
people that can add to the wave
are people in this group,
because that's like posting
to the wave.
Spam.
Getting those all day.
So we were trying to come up
with a way where robots could
actually be members of a group,
because that way they
would have permission
to do it.
So you could just
associate it.
If you had addresses and
associate that with the group,
maybe you could do it.
That's something to think about
when you're thinking
about the group support,
and also permissions.
Another thing was having
access to the multiple
revisions of the wave.
In the current API, you just get
the version at which the
event happened.
But a lot of people wanted
history access, and also along
with that restore access.
A human user can go through
history, and they can hit
Restore when they see
a version they
want to go back to.
That's something that robots
would find useful as well.
And this is sort of related to
robots also, just related to
permissions in general.
In Wave, there was in the
permissions model, there's
there was one owner of a wave,
and that owner had some
special properties.
Like only the owner could
set other people on the
wave as read only.
So since there was this
[INAUDIBLE] owner, we needed
to be able to have robots own
waves, which they can do by
creating it.
But a lot of times, you'd add a
robot to a wave and actually
want that robot to be an owner
and have all those owner
capabilities as well.
So this would need both
modification in robots and
just in permissions model
generally, as you need the
idea of being able to say that
there are multiple owners of a
wave, and being able to delegate
and say this person
can also be an owner, and
has all those owner
responsibilities
and privileges.
So that was all capabilities
for robots.
There's also just in terms
of the API, the
usability of the API.
Like right now, when you wanted
to actually modify
blips, you would have to create
image elements, and set
their attitudes, and
append them.
Or you could do this append
HTML operation.
It was basically doing a copy
and paste of HTML into a wave.
It was calling that code.
But the problem is that
when you did this--
HTML is nice, because we all
know how to write out HTML.
We write it out.
We've got this massive blob of
content that we're going to
put into the wave.
It's cool, it's styled.
But it doesn't really represent
what it's going to
become in wave world, so you
don't actually know for sure
what the indices are going
to be when you do HTML.
So we contemplated in having
some sort of Wave markup
language, not to introduce
more markup languages.
But some way that you could
just pass in a string that
represented both your content
and your style, similar to how
you do in HTML.
And have that be conveyed to
the wave, and have all the
indices be predictable.
But we didn't actually
really figure out
what that looks like.
And that would also be
advantageous, because right
now if you're going to do append
text and style it, and
append text and style it.
For example, Syntaxy
was a robot that
syntax highlighted code.
So it would change the color
like every three characters.
But every time it would set the
style annotation for the
color, that would be
another operation.
So Syntaxy actually did
more operations
than any other robot.
Because every single
one of those
was a separate operation.
So the other advantage of having
wave markup is that you
can do all this styling
in one operation.
So it really reduces the number
of operations you're
sending to the server.
So it should make it
faster as well.
A lot of you want to be able to
copy, like copy a blip or
just copy a range, like say
from character here to
character here.
Copy both the contents
and the annotations.
It's a very common use case to
actually want to copy stuff
from one place to another.
And we also talked about having
some API that didn't
actually require you to host
something on a server.
There were some robots
I wrote that were
literally one line of code.
But I had to deploy a whole App
Engine app just for that
one line of code.
I had one that would just remove
all the formatting from
all the style annotations
from a wave.
I shouldn't really have to run
a robot in a server to do
that, because that's a very
simple operation.
So we thought about some sort of
API that they wouldn't have
to run their own server for.
Now either it could be a
JavaScript API that's been
sanitized, that can actually
run inside the
context of the wave.
Or it could be maybe a
JavaScript API that we ran on
our own servers, so that at
least they didn't have to run
their server.
And Google Apps Script is
a good example of this.
Google Apps Script is actually
right in JavaScript, and it
gets run the Google Apps servers
against your current
doc or spreadsheet.
That was something-- and that
would also make testing a lot
easier too.
And it would also make it a bit
more in line with gadgets,
because gadgets are all
JavaScript, right?
So right now, if you wanted to
do something that involved
both robots and gagets, you
had to learn Python, JSON,
XML, HTML, CSS, JavaScript.
So that's quite a lot
of things to learn.
Granted, a lot of web
developers know it.
But if you can simplify that
stack, so everything's
JavaScript or something like
that, I think that would make
it a lot easier for
developers.
And finally, we wanted this idea
of a personal robot, or
maybe you'd call it
robot as an agent.
But when you put a robot on a
wave, it's basically acting as
another user.
And that makes sense in some
cases, but sometimes you want
a robot that's just acting
on your behalf,
and acting as you.
So Spelly and Linky, those are
agents and they basically act
like they're you.
They correct spelling,
and it looks like you
have that great spelling.
They add links, and it looks
like you did it.
So a really common time
we'd want this
is for emotion robots.
I would add my favorite emotion
robot to a wave,
because I wanted to convert my
colons and parentheses to
smiley faces.
But that doesn't mean that
everybody else on the wave
wanted to convert them.
And in fact, a lot of
times they didn't.
And I think some people might
have hated me for my prolific
use of emoticon robots.
So ideally I'd be able to say
like, listen, on every wave of
mine, run Emoticony as me.
So it would just be running as
an agent or personal robot,
and represent its
actions as me.
So that would require some
settings, and maybe some
thought about what that means
in terms of what the
robots could do.
But it's definitely something
that we wanted for very simple
cases, just like the
emotions one.
The other way you can think
about it is just letting
people write agents.
There's multiple ways of
thinking about that.
All right, so going
onto gadgets.
So the whole point of gadgets
was to be able to do basically
a little collaborative web apps
inside of a wave while
still retaining wavy qualities,
and making it so we
could really extend wave from
textual editing to visual
editing, visual collaboration.
So gadgets are really simple.
I think I have an
example here.
So basically, gadgets is a web
page that's embedded inside
some XML metadata, and all it
does is it has a shared state
which is a hash map.
It submits delta to that shared
state, and on a state
callback, it will
render the new
information about the state.
So it's a really simple API,
which is good, because it
actually was pretty
easy to use.
But it could be extended to make
it a bit more powerful.
One thing that people found it
difficult to use for was to
make games.
Because it was very
easy, actually, to
kind of hack the state.
So one thing that would make
that better is if every state
in the gadget state actually had
a modified by and a time
stamp that was set
by the server.
So you can imagine you have a
trivia game, and two people
are trying to answer
the question.
And if you don't know what time,
because this guy answers
then, and guy answers then.
If they come in and you set
different state keys, and the
server put a time stamp and a
modified by on both of them,
you can then compare them and
know for sure which user got
to the server first and
say, all right, that
user was the winner.
So right now you'd have to do
that in JavaScript using their
local time or using
some other way of
getting the server time.
That's pretty annoying.
So modified by and time stamp
would definitely help.
Some people wanted gadgets to be
able to actually listen to
state from other gadgets
within the same wave.
We didn't really figure out how
that would work, like if
you'd have to declare multiple
gadgets as a package or
something like that.
But that way, you could make
more of an application inside
a wave that was composed
of multiple gadgets.
And then there was a lot of
stuff about user experience.
So the point of these gadgets
is to take textual
collaboration to visual
collaboration, while still
being wavy.
So we have all these things
that we were lacking that
would have made gadgets
wavier.
So one simple thing is just
having participant carets.
So when you're in the wave,
you can see where somebody
else is editing, because they
have a particular colored
caret, and you see their name.
Gadgets didn't have access to
those colors, and they're
actually computed per wave.
So they didn't have a good
way of representing them.
So one simple thing is just to
pass the colors to the gadget
so we can have this
consistent view.
Another thing is that Wave
has this concept of
edit versus view mode.
There's a lot of confusion
about how to deal
with this in Gadgets.
Sometimes we told people that
they should only let people
edit the gadget in edit mode.
But there are a lot of people
that were very confused and
couldn't figure out why they
couldn't edit like a map, why
they couldn't add markers to the
map because they weren't
in edit mode.
So we never really quite
resolved whether gadgets
should be able to submit
states in view mode.
And that's the current way it is
now, but it's something to
think about from a user
point of view.
I think in Wave, now-- are we
on full wave edit mode yet?
Because we recently made a
change, at least internally
where when you start editing
something, the entire wave
becomes editable.
And I think that that makes the
gadget situation a little
bit easier, because at least
you can be editing both the
gadget blip and another
blip at the same time.
But it is confusing.
Another thing is that when you
wanted to have text inside a
gadget, you couldn't have
it be wavy text.
If you wanted it to be
collaborative text, you'd have
to come up with your own way of
doing that on top of this
simple shared state API.
And you could kind of do it, but
not really that well, and
it didn't feel like the same
experience that you had inside
the editor.
So we really wanted to be able
to say, like this part of a
gadget is actually a wavy text
field, and this part of the
gadget is a wavy text field.
And you could have single line
text areas, multiline text
areas, and those could
all be handled by OT.
And you could maybe represent
them somewhere in the wavelet
data documents or something like
that, and just surface
them in the UI of the gadget.
There's a lot of stuff
to do with sizing.
There's so many different types
of gadgets out there.
Some of them are very
small, but some of
them are very large.
Some of them are like
full-on web apps.
So we really wanted the ability
to minimize, maximize,
make the gadget full screen,
make the wave full screen, to
really make it possible to use
those collaborative apps whole
also making them not interfere
with the rest of your wave.
Another thing that we wanted,
which is kind of related to
this, is that there's a lot of
people who made these big,
collaborative web apps, and they
wanted to use this web
app gadget while also
chatting beneath it.
But you'd have to use the
gadget, scroll down to the
bottom, chat, use the gadget,
scroll down to
the bottom, and chat.
So one thing we toyed with is
the idea of a split scroll bar
where you could, say, split the
scroll bar here, and then
that way, you can actually chat
below the gadget, and not
have to keep scrolling
back and forth.
And you can see that being
useful not just for gadgets,
but also for editing
a document.
You have your one blip that's
your main document blip, and
then beneath that maybe you
have this more dynamic
conversation going on.
So if you could just split the
scroll bar at these arbitrary
points, and if we're going to
have a random scroll bar named
Scrolly, we might as well
do something with it.
It really would become a much
better experience for those
type of gadgets.
Diff-on-open.
Diff-on-open, you know when you
open a wave, you can see
what's changed by the yellow.
It was kind of weird
that you couldn't
see that with Gadgets.
I think it was just generally a
frustrating experience with
Gadgets data updates, because
your wave would go bold, and
you'd click on the wave, but you
weren't really sure what
had changed.
We now pass in the dif that
happens so that people could
do stuff with it.
But we don't really have support
for diff-on-open
So ideally, you would open a
wave, and if it was a gadget
that changed, you would actually
see in the gadget
some visual indication that
this was the changed
information.
Otherwise, I think users get
really frustrated clicking
away, that's bold, and not
knowing what the hell
happened, right?
And along with that in, the
inbox, ideally, you would
actually see when something
was bold, that blah, blah,
blah, gadget was changed.
Or blah, blah, blah,
change this gadget.
So you don't even have to click
the wave to know why
it's been bolded.
Along with that is sometimes
when you update the gadget
state, you don't actually want
the wave to go bold.
You don't want to have everyone
notified that this
wave has changed, because it's
really not that important of a
state change.
One way of doing that is letting
developers say, all
right, this state change isn't
going to trigger a bolding.
So we call that no echo.
Another thing is
actually having
different notions of state.
Like there's one state that's
kind of your data state, which
really represents the full data
that's in the gadget.
But another state could be
the user position state.
When you play Sudoku, you see
the positions of people inside
the wave, and each of those
is a state update.
But if you're not playing
Sudoku, you don't
really care about it.
The only people that care about
positions of the other
people are the ones that
are looking at that
wave at that time.
So you could have one state
that's actually the user
position state.
It's like the cursor state,
which we store in annotations
for the rest of the wave.
And that way, if you just change
the cursor state, you
wouldn't actually see
the wave go bold.
It would just be transmitted
to the
people that were watching.
Permissions, we had on Google
Wave, we had public waves that
became really popular,
and people would
put gadgets in them.
And unfortunately, sometimes
they'd put gadgets in them
that were somewhat evil.
By evil I mean like some of them
could actually redirect
and break out of the
frame, and do some
sort of phishing thing.
Some of them just used
up lot of memory.
So we wanted to do permissions
at least inside public waves,
so that if there was a gadget
there, you could enable it for
that wave, enable it always,
always trust ones from that
author, stuff like that.
Obviously, when it comes to
permissions, it all comes down
to the user interface and not
being really, really annoying.
So we had some drafts of
what that look like.
But this depends really on
whether you're having public
waves in your particular
system.
Or if it's more trusted and if
all of the gadgets people are
using are trusted, then maybe
you don't have that issue.
But it's something to think
about, because gadgets can
actually do a fair bit.
Along that note, we wanted
to have cajoled gadgets.
So Caja is a project to make
it possible to have safe
JavaScript APIs that can
only do basically a
whitelisted set of things.
Because right now, we have to
run Gadgets in an iframe,
because we don't want them to do
something malicious to the
area around them.
But the fact that we run them
in an iframe makes them
actually kind of slow to load.
Because we've got all
these iframes.
And if you use the plus one,
gadget, sometimes there are
waves that have like 100 plus
one gadgets in it, and that
can get really slow to load
those 100 iframes.
So ideally, for these little
gadgets that you kind of
sprinkle around, you would
actually be able to not put
them in an iframe, and
just render the divs.
But in order to do that, you
have to use something like
Caja, which will basically
sanitize the JavaScript, and
make sure that it's not using
anything that it can't use.
So we got pretty close to
that, actually, but not
releasing it.
Another thing is you might want
to actually find a way
for gadgets to go offline, if
offline or mobile support is
important to your particular
wave instance.
And we thought you could
actually maybe even use the
HTML5 application manifest for
people to declare all the
resources that their
gadget uses.
And then the gadget server could
actually store all those
resources if you go offline,
so that you have a good
experience if you're trying
to view those things.
Then we had installers.
So installers are the
way of actually
using robots and gadgets.
And basically, an installer
would put a little user
interface hook somewhere
into the client.
And then when you clicked it,
something would happen, like a
gadget would get inserted into
the wave, or a robot would get
added to the wave.
Those are the very common
ways of doing it.
So here we add the waffle
extension, we get a waffle on
our toolbar.
It inserts the waffle gadget.
We add the Submitty extension,
we get a new wave dropdown,
and it creates a new wave
for that robot.
So this is just a way of making
extensions a lot more
user friendly, so that people
didn't have to remember URLs
every time they wanted
a gadget.
And they didn't have to remember
addresses every time
they wanted a robot.
And they could make extensions
actually feel like they were a
native part of the
wave client.
And we did a good job
at that, but there's
definitely more to do.
We'll just manually go down.
All right.
So in fact, there are a lot more
hooks we wanted to add.
So at that time, we had the hook
for the new wave menu and
the hook for the
insert toolbar.
But there was a lot more.
And if you actually look at the
extensions docs, we did
document them.
A lot of these were in
experimental mode on Sandbox.
They just never made it to
non-experimental mode on preview.
So one thing was RegEx hook, so
that when somebody types a
particular pattern that an
extension recognized, the user
would get reminded to
actually put that
extension on the wave.
So if they type a phone number,
they would get a
prompt that said, do you want
to actually add the Twilio
extension to this wave?
So it's just a way of actually
reminding people, hey, you
have an extension that can
actually deal with some
information that's
in this wave.
And along with that, besides
RegEx, you could also build
something that recognizes
addresses, and let people
register, so that they only
react when there's addresses
in the wave, or just any sort
of semantic information.
So that's just reminding people
that there's something
useful that can be done with
that information in the wave.
Another thing is an attachment
hook, so that when you add an
attachment to the wave, and you
click on that attachment,
you would actually get an option
to do something with
that attachment.
Like you could go and, maybe
if it's a photo, you can
imagine people actually building
photo editors.
A lot of people wanted
to be extendable
photo editors for Wave.
So you'd click on a picture,
and it'd be like open it in
Picnik, and that attachment hook
would, maybe, insert a
gadget that would let you edit
that particular attachment.
Welcome panel hook.
That was simply just putting a
button in the welcome panel.
And that was pretty
much implemented.
A right-click hook, so when you
right-click, you can have
something there.
A blip menu hook.
Basically, anywhere in the Wave
client that there are
buttons that the client
provides, that's someplace
that a developer potentially
wants to hook into.
So it depends what your
particular client looks like,
what hooks you're going to
provide, but, really,
developers wanted all of them.
They wanted to be able to have
dropdowns on the toolbar.
It's pretty basic.
And also, a lot of them want
configuration popups.
So before you insert the gadget,
set some parameters.
Before you add the robot,
And I think you can implement
that just as actually maybe a
gadget itself, so that the user
would say, toolbar hook,
configuration gadget, and
then insert gadget.
And then maybe the gadget would
get the configuration
information in its state.
I think that would actually
be pretty simple to do.
Because then, you would
get experiences like--
because we basically do
something similar to this when
you click G+.
That's kind of like a
configuration thing, where I
can go and select that, and
that becomes something.
So you can imagine
using something
like that for a gadget.
One basic thing we wanted is
that when somebody clicks a
thing on the toolbar, we wanted
to actually send the
position that they were in when
they clicked that to the
extension, so that it could do
something like insert an image
wherever they clicked.
And a lot of people
just wanted to do
more and more actions.
We have basic actions like
insert gadget and add
participant, but people said,
oh, can I add a tag?
Can I set a title?
Can I insert an image?
So the thing is, people kept
requesting these things, and
we started realizing that they
basically just wanted the
Robots API inside of the
extension installer.
And I didn't show it, but the
extension installer is XML.
So once again, we have another
technology we're using.
The other thing you could
do is make this JSON.
So you could think of some way
of actually making it so you
could embed robot code inside
of the extension installer
instead of having to
invent new syntax
for all these actions.
Because a lot of these actions
are really mimicking the kind
of things that robots
can already do.
So you might want to actually
try and bring together Robot
API with this extension action
API, and maybe have it be the
same thing.
And then if you have it be
JSON, then everything's
JavaScript, and, whoo.
Another thing is having
a proper gallery.
We decided to do this kind of
weird thing where our gallery
is actually are wave based,
and eveything's in a wave.
And that was cool, I guess.
But the problem with this is
that that meant we didn't have
ratings, we didn't have reviews,
and it wasn't obvious
how to actually implement
ratings and reviews on top of
a Wave based gallery.
I think, actually, if you're
really gong to have a gallery,
you might want to just do
it outside of Wave.
Here's an example of what it
actually could look like.
So these are all the things.
And look at that.
I have categories over here,
because that's something that
we never really got to was
having categories.
And then when you actually
clicked on these, you could
go, and you could rate them,
and add comments, and you
could see the number of users.
So I think that if you're going
to have extensions, you
might want to just do an outside
of wave gallery.
And then use something like
the Wave This API to let
people try the gadgets
or install them.
So this is about
the discovery.
We also wanted it so
that if you saw--
if you were in a wave, and
somebody was using a gadget in
the wave, you just click on that
gadget and say, I want
that gadget, I want
that extension.
Maybe on every wave, you'd
see a list that said the
extensions that are being used
on this wave are this, and
this, and this, and you would
get a link to install it.
Basically, if a user sees
something being used on a wave
that somebody else has put
there, they should have a
really easy way of installing
that themselves.
So that would help
with discovery.
We had cool extensions, but I
don't actually think that they
got as much usage as they
deserved because
of discovery ability.
So those are extensions API.
We also have the Embed API,
which is really just iframing
the wave panel and putting
it on the page using the
JavaScript API.
So this was the JavaScript
API.
This was actually version two
of the JavaScript API.
And I think this is one of the
starter project for wave in
the box, is actually
to implement this.
But yeah, it's basically create
a new wave panel and
load this wave.
And you have a couple of embed
options, like showing the
header and footer.
But it's very basic API.
Some people would use it for it
embedding things on their
wiki, in their content
management system, for doing
live waving.
And, really, when it came to
features for the Embed API, it
was just all about
customization of the user interface.
People wanted different
color schemes.
Not every website is this color
of blue that Google uses
everywhere.
And what they're displaying.
People want to toggle this
off and that off.
They don't want to show
blip contributors.
They don't want to
time stamps.
They don't want to show
the participant panel.
Basically anything that you
could possibly toggle on and
off, they want to toggle
on and off.
For sizing, it was kind of
awkward to embed wave, because
you had to guess what size
they were going to be.
But you can't guess what size a
wave is going to be, because
people can add more stuff
to that wave.
So ideally, you could actually
say, just auto-size this wave
to be as big as it has to
be as people add to it.
Wouldn't be too hard to do.
People wanted to be able to
have comments collapse by
default when they
embed something.
I wanted a kind of user
interface which would be ideal
for encouraging people to
only follow a wave.
For the kind of waves that
are read only, and you're
embedding them so that people
can follow updates to them.
For the API change log, I would
like to just embed that,
and there would just be a big
follow button on that and
nothing else.
None of the rest of the UI.
Because there's nothing else
they can really do to that
wave besides follow it.
So that's kind of using
waves as RSS
feeds or Twitter streams.
And then people also want to
customize which part of the
wave they're seeing.
So being able to jump to a
particular blip, or even only
embedding that particular
blip.
And we did actually introduce
blip refs a few months ago,
which means that you have
an ID for each blip.
So this actually wouldn't be too
difficult to do, now that
we have that.
And then people want to embed
the search panel as well.
We actually started with the
ability to embed the search
panel, but decided to focus
on just the single wave.
Shouldn't be too hard
to do it, though.
Then we had the Data API, which
is basically the Robot
API, but you authenticate
it as a user.
And here I would say the feature
requests are largely
the same as the Robot API.
They wanted a bit more in terms
of realtime operations
and editing, because people
are using the Data API to
write their own clients.
But besides that, since it is
the same API, it was basically
the same requests.
So besides those APIs, some
other things we talked about.
Forms.
A lot of people were using Wave
to do forms, collecting
information from people, and
processing that, adding some
people on there.
So we did have form
elements in Wave.
There was, like, input
and password and
radio, and all of that.
So that was one way
of doing forms.
But some people also did
forms as gadgets.
Because then if you did a form
as a gadget, you could
implement your own simple
JavaScript stuff to say, oh,
if they did this then we're
going to show this.
And if they said this, we're
going to know this.
And we do some client
side verification.
So there were kind of two
competing ways of doing forms.
In the end, we were thinking
that the best way is probably
still as gadgets so that
you have more control.
And also the other thing with a
gadget is that you keep the
arrangements of everything
in the gadget.
So this is what we
were thinking.
Now I just remembered.
We were thinking for a form, you
want to have a form, and
you want people to fill
out the form.
So you do want them to be
able to edit the wave.
But you don't actually want them
to be able to move around
the elements in the wave.
You don't want them to move this
form element up here, and
you don't want them to delete
the gadget that is the form.
Because right now, if they can
edit the wave, they can edit
everything.
So we were thinking, actually,
that the owner of the wave
could lock certain elements in
the wave, and say all right,
this gadget is locked.
They can't move it, they
can't delete it.
Or say, this input element,
this text area is locked.
They can't move it, and
they can't delete it.
So then, you can keep the
structure of your wave, and
share that with somebody,
without worrying that they're
going to accidentally
delete parts of it.
So it's almost like the
permission to add to
something, but not take
away from it.
and that can apply to more
than just forms.
And we're also thinking for
gadgets, right now gadgets
have a shared state which
are subchildren
of the gadget element.
Another thing you could do is
actually just sync the gadget
state to data documents, because
it's very similar.
Data documents are basically
like hash maps of key values.
So you could actually have the
gadget state tied to these
data documents.
And then, it becomes a little
bit easier to interact with
them as a robot.
Another thing is that Dan was
actually a big fan of getting
developers to somehow use the
Doodad API, so that they
weren't using gadgets
to do everything.
So they're actually making their
own doodads to do stuff.
And that would make it probably
integrate a bit
better with the rest
of the wave.
We were playing with, actually,
wave templates,
which I saw the demo,
but didn't
actually see how it worked.
But basically you could mix and
match HTML with elements
of the wave so that you would
open up a wave and it would
look like a blog page, but
then parts of it would
actually be edible parts
of the wave.
And that was using Caja, the
thing we talked about earlier.
But I don't really know exactly
how it was working.
But it looked cool.
Because that way, people would
really have big control over
style of waves, and be
able to do stuff.
And then we're also thinking of
doing a search, like inbox
rendering API.
So right now, your search
results are
rendered the same here.
But imagine if a developer
wanted to actually do
something like the extensions
gallery.
So they wanted this custom
display, where you have the
thumbnail, the titles,
blah, blah, blah.
So we can actually have an API
where you hand the developer
the search results, or one
search result, and the
developer would say, render each
search result like this.
Maybe they'd specify some HTML,
some template, and that
way, you could actually
do custom displays for
extensions.
Like a to-do list extension.
When you click on your items
that you have to do, it would
be useful if a to-do list
extension that could actually
give you a panel here that you
could actually sort your tasks
by priority, and actually
visualize when they're due on
the side here, instead
of having them
look like normal waves.
So that, I think, would have
enabled people to really
customize Wave a lot more
for particular cases.
So those are some of the
ones I was thinking of.
But the cool thing is that we
were tracking all of our bugs
and feature requests
externally.
So if you are playing with the
APIs, you might want to check
out that list.
Some of these things are
actually really basic things
that if you guys are supporting
the APIs, you
should look at immediately.
But some of them are somewhat
farther out there, or just
restructurings of the
API entirely.
The APIs are cool.
I encourage you to actually just
think about what kind of
apps you want developers
to do.
Think about whether your
developers are internal or
external, how much
you trust them.
And that can influence what you
actually do with the API.
All right.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]